[Applaudissements]
il voulait trop vite la coopérative
elle est mon nom passer de trois jours
au mali
outre un sursaut
et
parce qu'elle avait des kilos en trop
[Musique]
même les
puissance était adolescente
qui n'acceptent pas qui ne supporte pas
la différence
c'est un sujet comme c'est touchant la
rue les bains exprimer ça et bien
montrer à tout le monde qu'il faut
s'adresser à ça au lieu de des petits
trucs de la vie est signifiante auquel
on se plaint alors quand des gens qui
souffrent a pas de chasse comme ça
ouais
l'umih art du jour après jour pour la
traiter de tous les noms
elle n'a jamais rien dit elle a fait le
dos rond
seppois sensibiliser les gens et pour
leur faire comprendre que le harcèlement
c'est pas un jeu et que ça peut faire
mal à beaucoup à des personnes elle aux
régionales elle avait peur
elle a préféré garder
sa souffrance la douleur
en fuite ou deux jours de son coeur
voilà on a réussi à transmettre le mot
qu'on a voulu le message et on espère
que ben sept personnes se rendront
compte de ce qu'ils font même si
inconsciemment qui seront beaucoup je
briserai de silence j'écris real
injustice et un jour ou l'autre vous
paierez pour vos primes
ainsi soit il ma soeur était belle qu'au
travers des petites elles avaient des
ailes elle rit sans cesse elle faisait
un jour je serai bratton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vous devrez toujours une soeur